i i feel like kenny g i'm sorry i
apologize i admit it uh i'm against
lyrics uh while democrats continue to
claim republicans are killing votes uh
voting in america they need to take a
look in the mirror like giving
immigrants the right to vote illegal
immigrants it's happening in major
liberal arts illegal not illegal what
legal legal immigrants can i continue
yeah but don't all right major liberal
enclaves like new york city which just
approved giving 800 000 non-citizens is
that okay we're all done yes thank you
uh the right to cast ballots in local
elections is this open ever going to be
over 14 other smaller jurisdictions have
similar laws and even leading democrats
like house democrat hakeem jeffries says
he's fully supports the idea
uh so
is there a worse idea on the planet than
than diminishing the idea of citizenship
in america jesse to fund the police
maybe okay
how dare you you know geraldo come on
you can't push non-citizens to vote in
u.s elections you can't do that you
wonder why the republicans were
suspicious about the ballots in 2020 and
opening you guys are openly pushing
non-citizens foreign
elections what if i walked across swam
across the rio grande and just started
voting in mexico
they threw you in jail so fast
i just get all of my friends we go swim
over to mexico and we vote so they build
the wall first
[Applause]
paid with toxic assumptions i believe
this is a bad move i believe that
vote the voting the right to vote is a
sacred right of citizenship and i i am
opposed to this idea thank you again i
was arguing for nothing i'm opposed to
this idea mr smarty pants because it
it dilutes the power of the vote and it
discourages people from that path
towards citizenship when they're here
legally to work hard and there's a
tradition and where they get sworn in
it's such a it's such a life-affirming
uh tradition in uh in the united states
and new york passing this non-citizen
right to vote new york would vote to
abolish the army
if
if it was on the ballot they would vote
in the real world we're actually
commenting about how people feel uh
don't have to project how do you feel
about this and are we heading this
direction i think that you'll find that
it will be as popular as defund the
police but it's also something that is
never going to happen number one kamala
harris is in charge well locally it
could happen right well yeah but but
what we're talking about is that the
democrats
biden's team is now saying build back
better because they're not going to be
able to get it done they're saying that
the voting rights bill is the most
important thing to do this will now
become and the media will follow
in this line of thinking
the most important
bill in front of the congress right now
is the voting rights one but the problem
is it doesn't really have a lot to do
with voting rights like they're
basically saying let's uh they don't
like voter id
okay
they don't like the other thing they
want to do is they want to divert public
money taxpayer money two political
campaigns it's a very unpopular idea but
they don't want to talk about that they
just want to say voting
everybody is for legally being able to
vote you have to give properly crazy
bernie's paying money that's exactly
what they want to do but that's that's
the one that's getting it because she
will sue she's litigious by nature uh
judge go ahead
i used to swear in newly naturalized
citizens it was the best day of their
lives it was the best day as a judge of
my day because i was always sending
people to jail
uh but they love america they swear
allegiance to this country they know our
history they know more about american
history than most americans do okay they
worked hard they paid for it they waited
in line they deserve to vote and they've
earned their citizenship these people
have not earned it if anything you talk
about you know uh the results of the
democrats actions well this is it baby
this is it we're opening up the borders
and now what we're going to do is we're
going to start the soft effort right and
we're going to have the non-legal uh or
the the green card holders vote and
that's local elections pretty soon
they're going to be voting in federal
elections this is just the beginning so
i think when we gave them licenses to
drive that's a point of identification
that they can use to register to vote
and i got to tell you this whole idea
all of a sudden they know the democrats
have been sinking in everything
everything's 60
everybody's against joe biden right all
of a sudden they had to turn it around
the gop is killing your voting rights
right they had to turn it around and get
on the offense right i think everything
you said is good i think we all kind of
agree i don't have a cur i married kurt
vonnegut's door to story but i do have
something uh that is relevant for this i
spent wednesday on ellis island uh with
michael weils who's an immigration
attorney and a historian walking through
and he tends to lean left to me he's a
democrat but he said uh i am not for
this and here's why he goes you swear an
oath to the country until you swear that
oath how dare you give up the right to
vote and almost every immigrant says one
of the sacred things the thing they look
forward to most after they get in
absolutely is voting and that's why i
said this is a non-start gun right okay
you know who represented john lennon and
the deportation his dad his dad michael
yes yes yeah and i was the witness i was
one of the witnesses did you ask kurt
vonnegut for his permission before you
kurtz
before i proposed yeah oh yes to his
daughter every night
that was his daughter he's a great man a
group those of you who just got a great
man
if you missed that everybody
because we're talking about a lot of
things right we have a lot of rewind
and by the far the most interesting man
in the world